if a shopkeeper has a number of goods in
the shop is zakat applicable on all of
the goods in the shop or just sum of
them
alhamdulillah as far as zakat on Goods
in the shop all the merchandise and
goods for trade and
commerce which are bought and sold
whether it be property land whether it
be animals foods machiner with the
stationary with the food stuff anything
all of them are liable for zakat
and whatever Goods that are there in a
grocery shop or whatever is there for
trade there should be an inventory made
and all should be noted down and once in
a year take the stock of all the goods
available whatever is there for trade
irrespec of what it is cars Vehicles
whatever it is they should be noted down
and zakat should be paid at 2 and a
half% whatever is there in the shop the
stock as well as the profit was
remaining at the end of the
year that are calculating on should we
noted down and zakat should be paid at
2.5%
except the
land of the
shop and the furniture and the vehicle
used for transport these can be Exempted
from zakat otherwise all the trading
stock everything should be calculated
for the okay thank you for the answer